es war wohl eine fatale kettenreaktion
eine tragödie die ihresgleichen sucht
ein us forschungsteam hat jetzt die
ersten 24 stunden nach dem einschlag des
dino killer hast du jeden vor 66
millionen jahren rekonstruiert ein
bohrkern vor der mexikanischen küste
gibt hinweise auf gewaltigen tsunamis
und weite buschbrände die die erde fest
im griff hatten
wie genau können wir uns den tag
vorstellen an dem ein großteil
allerdings sterben musste klicks zum
science und fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen dieser die nokia hast du ihn
von 66 millionen jahren hatte es in sich
das hat jetzt ein forschungsteam durch
die analyse eines bohrkerns aus dem
chicxulub krater vor der mexikanischen
küste herausgefunden
demnach könnten die meisten lebewesen im
umkreis von mehreren tausend kilometern
um den krater herum innerhalb weniger
stunden nach dem einschlag gestorben
sein
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
schorn kolleg nicht alle dinosaurier
sterben an diesem tag aber viel von ihm
doch wie genau liefen die ersten 24
stunden nach dem einschlag ab die
ereignisse sind wirklich kaum vorstellen
bei innerhalb von sekundenbruchteilen
wurde wohl die energie von 18 millionen
die roscheba bomben frei klar dass das
in einer riesigen naturkatastrophe enden
musste zusammengefasst hatte das wohl
nicht nur gewaltige zunahme ist sondern
auch ausgeprägte brände und eine enorme
abkühlung des klimas zur folge die sich
vielleicht sogar über jahre hinweg zog
das us forschungsteam hat die ersten 24
stunden nach dem einschlag das hast du
ihnen relativ detailliert rekonstruiert
im golf von mexiko entstanden bereits
wenige minuten nach dem einschlag
gewaltige zunahme ist verursacht durch
den plötzlichen versatz großer gesteins
mengen nach dem kollaps des rund 100
kilometer großen primär kraters bildete
sich ein krater ring
die so entstandenen tsunamis haben nach
ansicht der fachleute schon nach drei
stunden auch entfernte küsten erreicht
bis auf die höhe des heutigen us
bundesstaates illinois es könnten die
wassermassen damals vorgedrungen sein
doch es blieb nicht bei einem tsunami
höchst wahrscheinlich waren es mehrere
tsunamis die durch den golf von mexiko
rasten und flutwellen an den küsten
verursachten der einschlag
goethe zu erdbeben der magnitude zehn
bis elf eine globale katastrophe also
wenn auch weit entfernt von den küsten
wurden wohl komplette landstriche
überflutet doch als wäre das nicht schon
genug horror parallel hatten auch
unzählige feuer und eine gewaltige hitze
der erde fest im griff
es handelte sich um ein feuriges
entfernung das durch die hitze des
einschlages und die glühenden partikel
ausgelöst wurde diese gegen weit
verstreut auf der erdoberfläche hinunter
und das wohl bis zu 1000 kilometer
verteilt dazu heißt es in der aktuellen
studie
allein die einschlags wolke erzeugte
genügend thermische strahlung um
vegetation im umkreis von 1000 bis 1500
kilometern in flammen aufgehen zu lassen
doch dabei blieb es nicht denn gesteins
partikel die durch den ausbruch hoch in
die luft geschleudert wurden
regneten wieder auf die erde zurück sie
entzündeten sogar noch in mehreren
tausend kilometern pflanzenmaterial doch
wie lässt sich dieses szenario durch die
analyse eines bohrkerns rekonstruieren
konkret handelt es sich um einen
bohrkern aus dem inneren krater rannte
sogenannten chicxulub krater
diese eigenschaft krater hat einen
durchmesser von etwa 180 kilometern und
liegt im norden der halbinsel yucatan in
nordamerika unter fachleuten zählt er zu
den best erhaltenen einschlagskrater
weltweit daher unter sedimentgestein
begraben ist und so -versionen geschützt
ist der nun analysierte bohrkernen wurde
bereits 2016 entnommen und er enthüllt
wirklich aufregende details über den
untergang der dinos dazu schauen kolleg
der bohrkerne dokumentiert die
ereignisse direkt aus glauben sie damit
erzählt er uns über die einschlags
prozesse aus der position eines
augenzeugen vor allem die ablagerung
ermöglichen es den experten und
expertinnen die ereignisse zu
rekonstruieren
schon in den ersten 24 stunden nach dem
einschlag des asteroiden kam es wohl zu
einer ablage und vor mehr als 130 metern
an material eine echte premiere in der
geologie denn eine derart hohe
akkumulation wurde nach angaben des
forschungsteams bislang noch nie
aufgespürt gefunden wurden unter anderem
trümmerstücke sediment zu glas erstarrte
gesteins schmelzen und geschockte
quarzkristall der einschlag führte zu
einer gewaltigen explosion wodurch
sedimente und grundgestein aus
geschleudert wurden nicht nur der
asteroid sondern auch der groß
teil des untergrunds verdampften dabei
und das hatte folgen laut der fachleute
waren es höchstwahrscheinlich deutlich
mehr als 325 milliarden tonnen schwefel
die in die atmosphäre gelangten von
diesem wert gingen bislang aus doch im
krater selbst blieb durch den einschlag
traum noch schwefelhaltigen
untergrundgestein übrig wie die analyse
jetzt offenbarte
und das lässt die fachleute daran
zweifeln dass es bei lediglich 3 125
milliarden tonnen schwefel bieten der
aktuellen studie zufolge müsste es eine
deutlich größere menge gewesen seid so
oder so die kühlenden schwefel aerosole
sorgten für einen langen winter und
dafür dass kaum noch sonnenlicht auf die
erdoberfläche kamen dazu schreibt das
autorenteam unsere ergebnisse stützen
eine solche soll vater erosion bedingte
globale abkühlung und reduktion der
photosynthese als wichtigen teil
mechanismus dieser katastrophe bei der
analyse des bohrkerns konnten die
experten und expertinnen aber auch pohle
ablagerungen aufspüren dabei handelt es
sich um branddelikte die entweder vom
meer in den krater geschwemmt wurden
oder aber durch die luft dorthin
gelangten sie offenbar das gesteins
partikel die zur erde zurück regneten
auch noch in mehreren tausend kilometern
entfernung brennende inszeniert hatten
auch noch jahre nach dem einschlag
wüteten wohl feuer auf der erde
zudem konnte das forschungsteam dicke
ablagerungen im chicxulub krater
aufspüren diese stammt wohl vom wasser
das an den küsten zurückgeworfen wurde
diese enormen wellen überfluteten den
krater und das wasser stieg am rand des
kraters mehr als einen kilometer an klar
ist also das leben auf der erde hatte
kaum eine chance schon die ereignisse
die kurz nach dem einschlag auf der erde
ausgelöst wurden führten wohl zum tod
die organismen die die zunahme ist und
die verheerenden brände überlebt hatten
fielen dann dem einschlags winter zum
opfer
denn der senkte die mitteltemperaturen
um mehrere grad und sorgte zudem auch
dafür dass die sonne mehrere jahre
verdunkelt wurde den untergang der
dinosaurier fast experte schorn blick so
zusammen
sie wurden erst gegrillt dann gefroren
was wäre wenn die dinosaurier nicht
ausgestorben wären anklicken anschauen
und aston comics tv abonnieren
hammer kanal bis dann bleibt dran